>>> Out front now, a Russian
activist and member of pussy
riot jailed for 20 months in
Russia.
Russia recently opened another
criminal trial against her in
response to an art show that
included burning a portrait of
Putin.
I really appreciate your time.
You hear some of these Russian
women saying, one says, I
support Putin.
He does everything right, good
man, we love him.
Is this the view of most
Russians even now?
>> I highly doubt it.
It's really difficult to measure
what the public actually thinks
about Putin because it's
incredibly costly to criticize
him.
I've seen a lot of political
prisoners in Russia appearing
every day.
People are getting eight years
for pushing like button on
Instagram.
And it makes it incredibly
dangerous for people to say
something against Putin.
There was a case recently where
an 11-year-old girl made a
drawing with a Ukrainian flag,
and she was -- she's currently
in foster care, and her dad is
under arrest.
>> Foster care and her father
under arrest?
11 years old.
It's terrifying.
That brings it home.
You know, you know because you
spent almost two years in a
Russian prison.
What happens when you cross
Putin in any way.
What risks are people taking now
to speak out?
>> They can be arrested.
Their family members can be
arrested.
They can be murdered themselves
or to other friends of mine who
died because of criticizing
Putin and his regime.
It's -- it's not something that
I would advise people do, to go
openly against the war or
president Putin or at least if
they are in Russia currently.
They can make this choice for
themselves, but I wouldn't
advise it because it's worse to
risk your life and the life of
your relatives.
That's why whenever Russians are
being criticized for not doing
enough, I feel for them because
a lot of people I know, they
have to stay in Russia.
They don't have voice.
They simply cannot speak out
against the regime because it
can be just incredibly
dangerous, and they also cannot
leave the country because not
everyone is privileged enough to
be able to leave the country and
start a life somewhere else.
>> How bad is it being prisoned
in Russia?
You said you spent the 0 months
away from a child that you had,
and you had to serve that time.
>> It's -- it's really a hell on
Earth, especially when you're
being moved to the penal colony
where you have to work.
By law, you have to work, and
it's practically a slave labor.
Luckily, I was able to fight
against the system, and years
later after I got out of jail,
my prison boss -- ex-prison
boss -- was sentenced for slave
labor in the penal colony where
I served my time, I was forced
to sew police uniforms.
These days, people who oppose
Putin and who say something
against the war, they are being
sent to colonies to produce
military uniforms.
>> That's incredible irony,
horrible irony.
I know you just hosted a benefit
auction called my body, my
business.
It's performance.
It's punk but also art.
And this has been crucial to
you.
The auction is in honor of
international women's day,
benefitting reproductive
organizations worldwide.
Putin today actually came out
and spoke about national women's
day, and I want to play for you
part of what he said the holiday
means to Russia.
>> Translator: It is always
filled with special warmth and
meaning, kind, joyful, and
sincere feelings because this
reverence and respect towards
women and motherhood is an
unconventional value for us,
something we have been passing
on from generation to
generation.
>> That was today.
>> Such a clown.
>> That's really all there is to
say.
>> Pretty much.
>> Well, I appreciate your
taking the time and talking to
me.
>> Thank you.
>> You say what you have to say.